ام
[موسيقى]
ايتها الشعوب المسكينه البائسه ايتها
الامم المكابره في ادائها والعمياء عن
نعمتها انتم تطرحون وتدعون الاجمل والانقى
من رزقكم يختطف من امامكم وحقولكم تنهب
وتسرق وبيوتكم تعرف من الاثاث القديم الذي
كان لابائكم و تعيشون على نحو لا يسعكم
بعض الزهور ب انكم تمتلكون شيئا
يبدو انكم اذا ترك لكم نصف ممتلكاتكم ونصب
عائلاتكم ونصف حياتكم تعتبرون ذلك سعاده
كبرى
كلمات كتبها قبل اربع مائه وسبعين سنه
المفكر الفرنسي ايتيان دو لا بويسي
لمقارعه حقبه الاستبداد في فرنسا ولو ان
العروبه الراهنه عادله ل منحت كتابه مقاله
العبوديه الطوعيه
الجنسيه العربيه الى العناوين
البشير عند بشار دون سابق انذار
السياسي وسائقه الباص نحمده
الجزائريون اثرياء يشترون الماء
وكيل الوزير بالعراق بثلاثه ملايين
في هونغ كونغ يتضامن مع الامير
حرب وشيكه بين امريكا وروسيا
قال الرئيس السوداني عمر حسن البشير في
تصريحات لصحيفه عكاظ السعوديه ان بشار
الاسد سيقاتل بكل ابناء طائفته حتى
النهايه ثم سينتهي هو مقبول مرحبا كان هذا
قبل ثلاث سنوات
فكيف تبدل المشهد قبل بضعه ايام البشير
عند بشار ابشر يا صاحب المنشاه قريبا
تتغير اللوحه في القاهره من جامعه العرب
الى جامعه الرعب وصل الرئيس عمر حسن
البشير رئيس جمهوريه السودان بعد ظهر امس
الى مطار دمشق الدولي في زياره عمل حيث
كان في استقباله السيد الرئيس بشار الاسد
بعد ذلك توجه الرئيسان الاسد والبشير الى
قصر الشعب حيث عقد جلسه محادثات تناولت
العلاقات الثنائيه وتطورات الاوضاع في
سوريا والمنطقه في بلاد السودان لمع نجمه
ضابط من الاخوان تولى السلطه على مدى
اجيال معروف الحكم ليست فال من جلس عليها
التصق ومن اقترب منها احترق كثيره هي
التحليلات التي راجت واختلفت حول الزياره
التي قام بها البشير على متن طائره حكوميه
روسيه لكن المهمه امريكيه وفق الاندبندنت
البريطانيه
عشيه عمليه تركيه ضد الميليشيات الكرديه
سبقتها مفاجئه امريكيه بالانسحاب من الارض
السوريه فيما اعلام سوريا يقرؤها على
الطريقه المصريه رساله
سعوديه رئيس السودان في العلاقات مع دول
اخرى خصوصا السعوديه اليوم هذه الزياره
ممكن ان تكون تقارب وجهات نظر لكن اعلام
الخرطوم راى في هبوط البشير في مطار دمشق
محاوله تحليق بعيدا عن حلف ابو ظبي
والرياض يمكن السودان ان يدخل في تحالفات
استراتيجيه تعود بالنفع له على المدى ال
انه ما الفائده التي يجنيها من تحالفنا في
وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شويش اوغلو
يتكلم وكانه مولود من جديد ينسى كل مواقف
في بلاده ال مصره على رحيل الاسد اذا عادت
الانتخابات بشار الاسد فهل ستعملون معه
اذا كانت الانتخابات ديمقراطيه
ونزيهه على كل احترام
[تصفيق]
علم الاسبوع على اساسات القاهره كان
بعنوان الرئيس والحاجه نحمده كاميرات
اجهزه صوت واخراج كانت حاضره مع الفرق
الفرديه لتصوير لفته بالصدفه من الرئيس
السياسي حيث لاحق موكبه بالصدفه سائقه باص
للنقل العمومي واوقفها جانبا ليسلم عليها
الرئيس بالصدفه من مسافه الصفر وامنه لا
يبالي بركاب الباص الذين لم يتم تفتيشهم
الموضوع كله بالصدفه الا اذا كان الامن
يعلم بمواعيد تواجد الارهابيين عاده في
الباصات
مساءا كانت الاوركسترا جاهزه والحج نحمده
تنقلت بين الشاشات كواحده من المبشرين
الذين ظهر عليهم الرئيس في اليقظه
عبد الفتاح تحيه للسيده التي
في
العاصمه الجديده
[موسيقى]
رئيس الجمهوريه
طرقات وضباط وحواجز الكاميرات هل هناك
سابق معرفه بين الحجه والحكومه
معها الحكومه
الطريق بالذات بتعملوا معايير الطريقه
يعني
يعني انه يشوفون اه
بعد حمله الحد من النسل حمله جديده للحد
من الكرش اللي انتهت تطرق لها نفسك
شوف وزياده
اي انسان ماشي بالشراكه رجل كان عايز يعرف
وفيه يشوف هو
يعني ضبط
محافظ القاهره لا ينتبه الى وزنه اثقلت
الدهون دماغه وفشل في اختبار المليون من
اول جوله
لا
تعرف
داخل المحافظه
عملنا كبرى في الاربع سنين لفته
ان اعرف تمسكه بالحل عماد الدين اديب يتهم
الحكومه اللبنانيه بانها صناعه خارجيه
ويقول مطلوب بن سعد الحريري ان يكون رئيس
وزراء شكليا ويعيب على الاحزاب اللبنانيه
اهمالها الفقراء الحكومه اللبنانيه ليست
صناعه محليه انها اتهم كثير من القوى
السياسيه في لبنان
النهي عنها على الاقليم اكثر ما هي عنها
يعني خارج الحدود اكثر معين على الناس
المعطلين لم يقل احد للاستاذ عماد كيف
تتدخل في الشان اللبناني وتحرض الحريري
يخليك بمصر ابدا اصلا قال هذا الكلام على
شاشه اللبنانيه وساهم في اثراء وتنوع
النقاش السياسي حول لبنان عماد اعلن ايضا
عن ربيعا عربي جديد خلال مائه يوم قادمه
دون ان يتهمه احد بالتحريض على الانظمه
المائتين جايين ستار عواصم عربيه وعواصم
شرق اوسطيه تنتقل اليها عدوى السترات
الصفراء و ربنا يستر لم اجد في الاعلام
المصري اي احد بت اه يتناول المسائل يشكل
المنطق والموضوعيه لدى الناس كل التضامن
مع الزملاء الاعلاميين في مصر
ستهزم الرئيس السياسي عليهم انا في العلم
ابدا
واذا ما يكون وارجو انك لم داوود احد
يتناول المسائل عشان يشكل منطق وموضوعيه
لدى الناس في
[موسيقى]
فرنسا حتى السلطه لديها نقابه وتدعو الى
الاضراب احتجاجا على ساعات العمل الطويله
في مواجهه المتظاهرين
فمن سيواجه رجال السلطه اذا تظاهروا في
الشوارع الاجتياح الاصفر بلغ المجر تظاهر
الالاف في بودابيست احتجاجا على عدد ساعات
العمل المجريون يريدون التمتع بالحياه
مشكله شغل بالنسبه لرئيس الوزراء فان
قانون العمل الجديد وسيله لزياده دخل
العمال واله الابيب انتقلت السترات
الصفراء احتجاجا على غلاء المعيشه المعلن
عنه للعام القادم
في الجزائر اعلن وزير الموارد المائيه عن
تحسن المستوى المعيشي للجزائريين بدليل
استهلاكهم الكبير
لقرارات المياه المعدنيه
متناسيا ان المواطنين يدفعون ثمن المياه
اتقاء فاتوره المرض التي تسبب بها مياه
الدوله
عندنا اكثر من اربعين يعني
الاخر اللي بدو هذا ما يتعلق بمستوى
المعيشه منصب وكيل وزير في العراق بثلاثه
ملايين دولار فماذا عن تسعيره الوزير وما
هي الاموال التي س يجنونها من الوزاره
والله العظيم مناصب وكلاء الوزارات وانا
مسؤول عن كلامي ولدى شهود
اذا ما
اعلنت ال وكيل وزير يدفع ثلاثه مليون
دولار في الضفه الغربيه اجهزه السلطه ليس
لها سلطه الاعلى ابناء جلدتها تضربهم
وتعتقل هم كما فعلت مع انصار حماس في
الخليل خلال مسيره ب ذكرى انطلاقه الحركه
من هو اسمه
ويلعب المستوطنين هل هو صلاح الدين الظاهر
بيبرس
ام عز الدين القسام
ولا واحد انه محمود عباس احييكم باسم
الرئيس محمود عباس
الذي اصبح اسمه
يرعب نتنياهو وقطعان المستوطنين
ونحن نفرق بين السلطه والذي يعتبر الشريف
وبين حماس الذي اعتبره
عدو بي محمد وهبي عاش في هذه الدنيا ثلاثه
اعوام ثم توفي قبل ايام مريضا على لائحه
انتظار سريع محمد طفل فلسطيني من مخيم نهر
البارد شمالي لبنان
والقاتل هو الفقر والهويه
على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفعل استراليا على لسان رئيس وزرائها
تعترف بالقدس عاصمه لاسرائيل القدس
الغربيه هي عاصمه اسرائيل ونتطلع لنقل
سفارتنا اليها عندما يكون ذلك عمليا رد
الفعل جامعه الدول العربيه تدين هذا
الاعتراف الرد على رد الفعل العربي لم يات
من افيكدور ليبرمان ولا من حاخامات حركه
كان بل من الوزير المتربع على خارجيه
البحرين الشيخ خالد ال خليفه
وادان ادانه الجامعه ووصفها بالموقف غير
المسؤول
دخل الكاتب السعودي الصهيوني دحام العنزي
يفاجئ الامتين الكوريه والصينيه يعلن ان
ما وصفه بحريه الراي في السعوديه تسمح له
ب ترويج افكاره
التعاونيه مع اسرائيل من قلب الرياض لكن
هذه الحريه لن تتسامح مع رفض المعتقل ه هل
بلير للتطبيع
يوم من الايام في شوارع عربيه
ان السعوديه لديها
حريه الراي ومن هذا المنطلق انا اطرح
افكاري وارائي فيما يتعلق بالصراع وليس
الخلاف الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
تنافس المدعون في سهره سعودي اربعه وعشرين
على نظم المدائح الاميريه فهو صقر بل هو
نجم في السماء انه قوى امين
وكريم وصف الرئيس الامريكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان زعيم المتمكن من
سلطته وسمو الامير محمد حقيقه هو فقط
السياسه
والمنجزات حقيقه التنمويه على مستوى
العالم هو القوي الامين رغما عن انف اي
شخص يحاول ان ينال من القاضي
والتراب في الارض اذن الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد وضمن سياسه العصا والجزره
يجدد دعمه ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمه
يحتفي اعلام الرياض من دبي بالمناسبه دعوه
بعض النواب ضد السعوديه ولي عهدها التي لم
تجد تفاعلا داخل مجلسي الشيوخ والنواب رد
عليها بجمله واحده خلال حوار تحميل
المملكه يعني دعمه للامير محمد عدد محدود
من الشيوخ اجماع في الكونغرس بالمائه على
ادانه الامير
شخصيا يرفض موقف مجلس الشيوخ ويتضامن مع
قياده المملكه وفق ما نشرت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه
ولم يعرف حتى الان ما هو موقف مفتي لاس
فيغاس ولا موقف مفتي موناكو
لكن وزاره الخارجيه والقنصليات عبرت عن
رفضها التدخل الكونغرس اخيرا فهل سينتفض
عادل الجبير كما انتفض على كندا صرح مصدر
مسؤول في وزاره الخارجيه تستنكر الموقف
الذي صدر مؤخرا من مجلس الشيوخ في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمملكه تؤكد
رفضها التام لاي تدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
او التعرض لقيادتها امير قطر الشيخ تميم
بن حمد ال ثاني لم يغير موقفه في مساله حل
ازمه الخليج ارفعوا الحصار وا قبلوا
بالحوار واحترموا الجوار وينطبق ذلك على
ازمه الخليج المتمثله بحصار بلادنا والتي
لم يتغير موقفنا في حلها لرفع الحصار وحل
الخلافات بالحوار القائم على الاحترام
المتبادل وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول وزير خارجيه البحرين خالد ايضا لم
يقبل وغرد كما تغرد كتائب القحطان
الالكترونيه بما لا يليق ب موقعه كوزير او
حتى كناشط مرموق خلف الحضور وبدل ان يروي
قصته في عالم المال والاعمال يواصل محاوله
منافسه ارسطو في طرح النظريات السياسيه
وجديده دعوته الى اسكات الاصوات واستلهام
التجربه الاماراتيه
يجب علينا الدول العربيه فكر تاخذ نسخه من
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده وتطبقها
عندهم هذه ال البرلمان واللا وعضو مقديشو
هذا هذا يجب يلغي والسنه طويله يجب ان لا
زمان كان وتسكت في السعوديه مهرجانات
غنائيه صاخبه في افتتاح
في جهات الاختلاط والرقص كثيره ولن نعرض
منها شيئا ما جرى يجري في كل الدول
العربيه فلماذا ننتقل السعوديه بالذات
التي يستحسن من الاخوه في السعوديه
الحد من استخدام شعارات دوله التوحيد
والشريعه والسنه عيشوا حياتكم عشرين
ثلاثين واربعين
لكن لا تتعلم باسم الدين
ان وال في جده يوزع الهدايا على الاطفال
والفنانه السعوديه اخير تستغرب انا من
بدنا نشوف الثقافه السعوديه سانت كلوز
يعطي هدايا الاطفال المسلمين عيد الاضحى
امريكا لان وعيد الاضحى المسيح يبدؤوا
[موسيقى]
وطاوله سعودي يدعى فهيد الشمري على الشعب
اللبناني باكمله واتهمه بالسرقه والاهانه
شملت ايضا كل شعوب بلاد الشام وغابت عن
ذاكره الشتاء صور نخبه بلاده من امراء
ووزراء ورجال اعمال وهم يساقون الى السجون
بتهمه سرقه المليارات والحبل على الجرار
فانا انصح اه اصحاب الشركات فى السعوديه
والخليج انت بهم من اللبنانيين لا يمس
كونهم اداراتهم ابدا هذا اذا مش كاداره
هذا اولا
اه دكتور يعني الفنيين
كونهم ادارات والفلسطينيين مثلهم
كل ها البلاد هذي الشاب ما لهم في الاداره
لو في الاداره كان بلاده متطوره بتقول لي
اللبنانيين انسان هم طويل و مش رح يسكتو
لك عليها بقول لك ممكن بس تقول لي ايدهم
طويله الها الكرافات هي اللي انت بتلبس ها
طويله على رقبتك
طويله على رابع
اصبح بامكان المواطن السعودي السفر في
الديب و جالسا بين حقائب ركاب الطائره
الجالسين فوق فكيف سيسافر اذا جدد الكرام
لولايه جديده في البيت الابيض نقدم لكم
درجه الركاب الجديده درجه خدمه الامثله
وال مستحدثه خصيصا لتصميم تجربه طيران
فريده باسعار غير مسبوقه ممكن اول مره
على مستوى العالم لكن يجربها
من جده ممكن تسافر في منطقه خزانه الان
عشان توفر انها ليست كبيره خفيه بل برنامج
بالمباشر وعلى قاعده يللي ما اعجبوا
يغيروا القناه مذيع سعودي اربعه وعشرين
وال مذيعون قليله
السعوديه ستنتصر في حرب اليمن الحوثيون
سينتهون بالكامل هذه الحسابات
الاستراتيجيه
كشفها مولانا محمد بن علي
الشيخ
المنطقه انظر الى الشمس
[موسيقى]
الله العاصمه ورايت وارد وكان طويلا
الطفل الصغير واظهرت الى
نظيفا العاصفه فهمت الله والله اكبر
الشمس تدل على اليمن
وجدتها وقومها يسجدون للشمس كانت هذه سبب
والعاصمه الحزم والاب الملك سلمان حفظه
الله والثور الدين وهذا دليل على نصر
المملكه في الحرب وفي من ام دبيلو
والخمسين حرب عالميه ثالثه وشيكه بينما
حضاري الشر براي الشيخ الشنقيطي روسيا
وامريكا التي تقود مع السعوديه العالم
والانسانيه الى مرافئ الامن والسلام
والسيد
احدهما الاخر وانا بجانبهما او بجانبها
وبجانب صغير ولكنه لم يبدا
ما شاء الله حاويه تدل على الدنيا
والحنين يدل على قوتين عظميين ستقوم
بينهما حرب ياكل بعضهم بعضا ن الحمد لله
اللهم اجعلها بينهم اجعل باسهم بينهم شديد
قد تكون روسيا وامريكا
[موسيقى]
الختام كما البدايه من كلمات المفكر
الفرنسي ايتيان دو لا بويسي ان مقاومه
القهر والبؤس لا تمر عبر القتل والعنف لان
عبوديه الشعوب طوعيه فهم الذين يقتلون
انفسهم بانفسهم
وهم الذين يخضعون طوعا الظلم والاستبداد
ليش وهون الطبيعه البشريه المسؤوله على
الكرامه والحريه لا تسعى الى التخلص من
الطاغيه بل اعرب فقط عن الرغبه بذلك
احزموا امركم على رفض الخنوع وها انتم
اخرى ليس المطلوب دفعه او زحزحته انما فقط
الكف عن دعمه ولسوف ترونه تمثال عملاق
نزعت قاعدته من تحت قدميه فهو ي يتحتم ب
ما جنت يده
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم
ام
[موسيقى]